deep within Jordans desert canyons lies
an ancient treasure the stone city of
Petra this massive hand-carved
metropolis provides a window into an
ancient civilization a hidden network of
tombs monuments and elaborate religious
structures are carved into the sandstone
cliffs believed to have been settled as
early as 9000 BC it developed into a
thriving capital of the Nabataean
kingdom this culture ruled much of
modern-day Jordan from the 3rd century
BC until the 1st century AD it's a
three-hour drive from the capital city
of Amman and 2 hours from the Red Sea
port town of Aqaba reducing Petra to a
single day trip is a common mistake the
site spreads out over a hundred square
miles four times the size of Manhattan
spend at least one night in wadi musa
the closest town to the site and plan
your sightseeing as a series of steep
terrain hikes wild donkeys camels and
horse buggies can hasten travel time
between highlights most of the sites are
best reached on foot
licensed guides have exceptional
knowledge and can add a deeper dimension
to your visit by showing you secret
tombs and hidden details sunrise and
sunset are when petra truly glows so
come early and stay late
you
[Music]
you